so i talk about it a lot in the book and
i do think that there's this difference
between clinical burnout which is a
really serious thing that you get signed
off work for that is a medical term
that is hugely debilitating all of this
and i also think that there is this kind
of idea of mini burnout and i would say
that a lot of people
now
have mini burnout because where you
don't leave work at the office if you
have an office you definitely don't
leave work at the office if you work
from home you also even if you then
think you do going on social media say
every time i go on social media i'll
probably see five different activewear
competitors i'll probably see
50 different influencers who are doing
better content than i do i will probably
see 10 different friends who have more
successful relationships fashion senses
like all of these things we are working
in some way
all the time
and i think that it's like that's why
these older generations look at us and
they're like oh [ __ ] boho like you've
got access to social media and it's
burning you out because you're looking
at other people's clothes but i do think
it's really it's the same as talking
about the 24-hour news cycle it is our
brains are never fully relaxed and
therefore they never get full response
respite in order to reset
and
you know go again like if you're swiping
through tick-tock every night before bed
your brain is not going to rest in the
same way and you're fatiguing yourself
and i do think that a lot of and that's
not to say that you know i don't do that
sometimes and i will be the first to say
that i have so much advice and i take
absolutely none of it but i also think
that
we as a generation are increasingly
burnt out based on the fact that work
doesn't just look like work emails just
aren't just on a computer your office
isn't just on an office
your phone isn't just a phone like all
of these things
and i think that you know the aim of the
book was to give also a certain amount
of tools to deal with that i think my
signs in particular of burnout
are i think i've been slightly burnt out
for a very long time now i think i've
probably been slightly burnt out
as soon as i even started slowing down
the the social media stuff which was
originally i think i only realized that
when i did slow it down i was like oh my
god
this time it's not like feeling like
i've got a lot of time back it's just
feeling like a bit of a breath of fresh
air just because i was also doing the
degree at the same time and
also
bombarded with so many opinions positive
negative all the same like
and i think that i've never actually
fully recovered from that and i think
that it's also part of the fact that we
don't talk about one of the downfalls of
passions
is that if you're working on your
passion you're probably not going to
realize when you're burnt out because
there's this like necessity whether
internal or external because it's a
business that you put into a lot of
money into or internal because you
believe in it so much and you love it
and you really want to succeed it's like
when you're working for ages and you
don't realize until you look up how long
you've been working for and you're
really like your whole brain's just
zapped and i think that we don't talk
about how
exhausting working on something you're
passionate about can be
because you exert yourself that much
more now that's not to say that it's as
like i've mentioned it's not to say that
it's not a hugely privileged position
because it is but i also think that when
we're encouraging like work on your
passion like all of this also
remembering the fact that if you're
there every day so trying to make this
idea into a business and so trying to
make this work and so trying to get your
side hustle off the ground and all of
these things you're also allowed to feel
burnt out hey friends thank you so much
for watching if you enjoyed this clip
then click here for the full unedited
episode and if you like that then do
please consider subscribing to the
channel it means a lot thank you so much
and have a great day bye